we um it felt like i could tell my side
of um harry and put across how he was to
us
and how much he meant to us as a whole
family
um and so hopefully they could
understand
our pain and our loss and the
devastation that we have suffered in the
last
22 months while we're waiting to get
this far and
hopefully they could see why we've
gone this far why we've carried on with
this campaign and why we have agreed to
you know come to the states in these
difficult times to
show them how much our son meant to us
as as
as the whole family and how much we miss
him and
how much he is missed by all of our
family
what happens now in this civil case i
understand it's going to be heard later
in the year what's the next process the
next stage
we're still yet to find out you know
we're very much in the hands of our u.s
lawyers
um we we're just trying to take things
day by day
they tell us on a need to know basis
depending on
how we're coping on any particular hour
let alone any
particular day so we've taken a day away
from the us lawyers today we fly home
back to the uk tonight and we
are desperate to come home
and then we'll have some time with our
family and then we'll pick back up with
the lawyers and we'll take it from there
this is having a huge mental toll on
both of you and and the rest of the
family isn't it pursuing all this
yeah it's um it's extremely difficult
um it's exhausting
you have to dig deep every single time
we're asked to do something every single
time
we put ourselves out there to
to keep striving towards getting justice
for our boy
the determination never wavers the
promise i made will never
will never be forgotten um
but yeah it's very very hard you know
we've we've all had to reach out for
some help
we're not ashamed to say that we've had
to do that
i think we're pleased that we've done
that it's given us a little bit of
strength back to
to carry on doing what we're doing but
i'd just like to thank everybody for
their ongoing continued support both in
the media
and outside of the media you know all
our supporters in the uk and in the us
and indeed the rest around the world but
without without any of you we wouldn't
be here
but it is hard but we're not going to
give up until we've got justice for our
boy
you